kamala harris to the rescue
well kamal is finally taking her big
trip to europe next week
poland and romania to be exact
in a point to show support for ukraine
and nato the vice president will meet
with leaders of both countries to
discuss their response to russia's
invasion
it's no surprise she was chosen to go
since she's always been a foreign policy
whiz
you know joe is i love talking with joe
about a lot of these issues and you know
joe he i think he said it quite well he
says you know foreign policy it might
sound complicated but really it's
relationships so just think about it as
relationships
and so we know this in our personal and
professional relationships
here now douglas murray author of
madness of crowds it's just about
relationships yeah right it's
straightforward the whole thing well
it's not that complicated if people
could point me to one thing camel harris
has solved
there might be reason for the europeans
to have hope but jesse you know very
well nobody can point to one thing she
solved she was given uh the southern
border crisis two million illegal
migrants came across the southern border
in the last year so
that's just one of the crises she's
failed to solve
look at anything else she's been given
in her
strange portfolio not solved any of it
so who do you send to solve the most
intractable problem of the moment and
the potential for world war three but
kamala harris maybe he's sending her
because he doesn't want to solve the
problem
maybe he thinks that you know we we drag
this thing out you let russia fight this
thing forever he doesn't want a quick
fix the best way to do that send kamala
it's possible he is expecting that
kamala will say so many banal things for
such a long time that the conflict will
be over by then
um remember remember she went to munich
the other day and she told the europeans
that they had to remember they were in
europe yes and that there was a war and
therefore this meant there was a war in
europe right and wars
was bad and kamala told them that and
she told them where they were and that
war was bad so so if we can expect more
of that from her then yes it's possible
that that joe biden simply sent her to
just just keep this running till the end
do you think because the last time she
went there the very day she left putin
invaded
so do you think he's going to tweak the
united states again on the the week she
shows up he's going to he's got maybe a
trick up his sleeve
you know obviously it's all just about
relationships
you know what it is about relationships
so all that she needs to do is to get a
better relationship with vladimir putin
and if she could just get in there charm
the kremlin then maybe they'd stop i
mean this is this i mean on a serious
note really we should not be joking
about this
it is the last person that i would be
sending i spoke to a ukrainian mp
earlier who just said you know that how
devastated they are that joe biden has
done so little for them and and and this
even even more than little he sends his
vice president he's got to send cable
because he's in delaware you know
delaware is they've got a lot going on
in delaware this weekend all right but
let's take care of that relationships
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else